listen Herschel Walker has been caught
in another lie This Time by his own
mother by his own mother you might
remember that one of Herschel Walker's
kids Christian Walker turned against him
and denounced him early last week
calling him a liar calling him a
hypocrite well now Herschel Walker's Mom
is saying that story he told about being
full-blooded Cherokee Native American
that story absolutely isn't true The
Daily Beast reporting Herschel Walker's
full-blood Cherokee claim is news to his
mom let's start with the video clip this
is from a couple weeks ago here's what
Herschel Walker had to say about his own
supposed Native American ancestry
wait wait I found something out I found
something out and then over here I found
something out and then I'm gonna end
this I found something out my mom just
told me that my mom uh grandmother was
full blood Cherokee
so I'm Native American I was like oh
hello so I'm I'm a I'm a super mutt I
don't know what I am but this is what
was so funny
this wasn't so funny I said uh mom uh
why you never said anything to us
yeah so he found out that he's full
blood Native American turns out his mom
has no idea what he's talking about
there is a very a good Daily Beast
article here which let's see if I can
pull up we uh have gotten a very
unfortunate paywall here all of a sudden
and I want to have this uh for us so
that we can see it um his mother
indicating she is not aware of such
family history
um if you check out the article you see
that Walker's mother Christine spoke to
Huffington Post and said she has no idea
if an immediate ancestor was
full-blooded Cherokee she said she grew
up hearing stories about her father's
mother being kin to the tribe clarifying
that her grandmother was believed to be
related to Cherokee people's in some way
but didn't know how doesn't know how far
back the Cherokee Heritage goes and has
no further information herschel's
Herschel Walker says I'm full blood
Cherokee recall that when Elizabeth
Warren had actual stories in her family
about being Native American this is the
treatment that she got because you know
we're talking too soon we got a year and
a half left it's like when I called
Pocahontas Pocahontas I should have
waited
six months because she then went out and
got that test
1024
and I've always said I have more Indian
blood in me than she has in her and I
have none I have none
but it's more than she has 1024.
[Applause]
and this went on for months with
Elizabeth Warren but I brought it up too
soon so I don't talk about it anymore
but if she should be the candidate which
I tend to doubt
but if she should be we'll bring it up
again and I think it'll be very
successful
1024 how about this I was driving her
crazy
so she went out and hired a guy to check
the blood
I'm sure he had a lot of fun doing that
he checked her blood
and found out
and he could have been India okay so uh
that that persisted for months now
Herschel Walker just straight up lying
his own mother says I have no idea what
he's talking about within two weeks and
silence Silence from the very same
Republicans who were saying oh Elizabeth
Warren did something so wrong stolen
privilege and all these stolen benefits
by claiming to be Native American which
by the way wasn't even true
um the double standards you know I don't
really care who's Native American I
don't really care about you know if
there's if there's a cognitive issue or
a health issue whatever fetterman Walker
would just be consistent guys that's all
I'm asking for just please be consistent
let me know your thoughts find me on
Twitter at dpacman we will take a very
brief break and be right back
I often have a very hectic schedule and
I don't always have the time to plan the
exact nutrition of all of my meals but
our sponsor athletic greens just makes
it easy to make sure I'm getting the
nutrients I want I've been using it for
almost a year now and it's great ag1 by
athletic greens is a delicious
plant-based blend of 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics from
whole food sources if I have just one
small scoop of ag1 a day I know I'm
getting the nutrition and nutrients that
I want that support all of the things
that are important to me the only
alternative would be to take 20
different vitamin pills and things every
day I'm not doing that I don't want to
do that ag1 is super tasty you can put
it in a smoothie I drink it straight
achieving good nutrition and feeling
your best does not have to be
complicated you can make AG one part of
your daily routine the way I have done
when you go to athleticgreens.com Pacman
you will get a one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs the
link is down below